wait what kind of what what kind of
weapon are we talking about here the
thanos killing kind
don't you think that we should all have
a weapon like that no you simply lack
the strength to wield them your bodies
would crumple as your minds collapsed
into madness is it weird that i want to
do it even more now
a little bit
bring me that one
[Music]
bring us the thanos cut so everybody was
asking about the extended cut of
infinity war that was being talked about
this past week so if you didn't hear the
news
supposedly there was about 30 minutes of
thanos backstory that was cut from the
film
they've already leaked what the dvd
bonus features are going to be there's
about 45 minutes worth of footage so
it's way more than people
expected i'm still doing that weekly
giveaway for the blu-ray all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video i'll name a
new winner at the end of this
the actual bonus features are pretty
standard is basically deleted scenes
extended scenes and then a couple
featurettes there's about 10 different
clips listed so i'll say what the clips
are then i'll explain
what's actually in those scenes there's
an intro from the directors that's a
couple minutes long that's just them
sort of introducing the project like
this is the biggest thing that we've
ever done in our entire lives we're
gonna see you during avengers 4.
please do buy tickets to that next movie
when it drops next year there's a gag
reel that's only a couple minutes long
it's not quite as long as i would expect
then there's a bunch of featurettes
there's one called the battle in wakanda
pretty self-explanatory
it's the longest one it's about 11
minutes long obviously the battle on
titan in the battle in wakanda were the
two biggest scenes that they
filmed so it was like a whole bunch of
work for very little screen time
the one for the battle of titan is only
about nine and a half minutes long
this one called the kingdom of thanos
that's probably when they're on his ship
called sanctuary 2. remember sanctuary
is where he's from sanctuary 2
is the name of that giant ship there's
one called the new teams that's probably
just for all the different groups
that you have before they come together
in the battle of wakanda in the battle
on titan like you have the guardians you
have team iron man and spider-man
you have cap secret avengers then you
have all the people in wakanda
there's one called the decision of a
father obviously that's when they're on
formir and he's trying to get the soul
stone and he has to think whether or not
he wants to sacrifice gamora there's
only three straight up deleted scenes
that they list one is called happy has a
perspective
that was probably part of the earlier
pepper tony scenes when they're in the
park before doctor strange shows up
there was actually a report that they
had a whole bunch of cameos in that too
there were a couple celebrities and it
was just robert danny jr going on and on
and on like he could improv
all day he's fantastic so obviously they
just cut that short because they wanted
doctor strange to get there relatively
quickly
there's one called the hunt for the mind
stone that's actually pretty short
that's probably cap's secret avengers
versus proxima midnight in corvus glaive
because when thanos comes for the mind
gem it's not so much a hunt as it's him
running a gauntlet of avengers just
stepping on them one at a time till he
rips it right out of his forehead
the next one is called the guardians
find their groove and it's actually a
pretty long deleted scene it's like
three and a half minutes long almost so
it's probably
before they pick thor up it's probably
just the guardians
so a lot of you are wondering like what
are people talking about the thanos cut
the 30 minutes of his backstory that was
cut from the film
the reason why people think that this
exists is because jim starlin
implied that there was about 30 minutes
worth of thanos backstory that they cut
from the film it comes down to a
quote by norman mailer all true stories
end in death
these guys are playing massively
high stake games and if see people don't
die occasionally it's
there's no reality i mean it's not
reality to begin with but
we have to at least give it a semblance
of reality every so often now he didn't
say that they filmed it
and it was just sitting on a shelf
somewhere he said there was about 30
minutes explaining
what had happened to thanos that brought
him to this point so like when he tells
tony you're not the only one that's
cursed with knowledge
when he tells gamora that he failed to
do what was necessary
before but he won't fail now then he
gives the backstory explainer for the
planet titan to doctor strange using the
reality gem
it used to be a paradise genocide
but random just passionate fair rich and
poor alike
they called me a madman
what i predicted
it sounds like this 30 minutes worth of
backstory is just
more stuff of him before the events of
infinity war
like we got that scene and age of ultron
where he says fine i'll do it myself
presumably that's happening a couple
weeks before the beginning of infinity
war so he goes to take the power stone
because the timeline of infinity war is
relatively short so even though we don't
get to see him destroy
zandar you have to imagine that that's
happening relatively quickly before the
beginning of infinity war because he
gets the power stone then he immediately
goes to asgard
shows up and that's the end of thor
ragnarok and you see the beginning of
infinity war
right after he's killed half of those
asgardians but per these special
features there's like no
giant 30-minute special scene of thanos
explaining his backstory
so it sounds like some of that might not
have been filmed but for those of you
that are bummed out that there is no
like giant
thanos cut that they're going to release
he actually did explain a little bit of
his backstory and the filmmakers talked
a little bit about what they changed
from the comics because you do get a lot
of thanos's backstory during the thanos
rising comic book
the biggest changes that they made is
that they completely got rid of the
character
death so when thanos was a child he
started to see a friend that would pop
up and try to get him to do
really twisted things eventually as he
got older he realized that it was the
cosmic entity death
trying to push him down the path to the
snap like trying to turn him
into the person that he is today the
other big change is the downfall of the
planet titan
so in the movie they explained that it
was because of the resource
problem and that's why thanos was more
of a tragic hero i tried to save them
by killing off half the population and
they called me a madman
in the comics he just came back to his
home planet and eradicated them all
himself
the comics make him much less
sympathetic those stories are mostly
about his relationship with death like
all these
big crazy things that he does erasing
half of all life in the universe
saving the universe there's been a lot
of stories where thanos becomes the
anti-hero they mostly revolve around his
relationship with
death so if there is any like extra
thanos scenes that they're sitting on
then they'll release with future special
editions of the blu-ray is probably just
more scenes of him
talking about his backstory i don't know
that they filmed a lot more of this
flashback on titan
most of the scenes that they cut for
time are just extra improvs like they
said they would do the script a couple
times
then they would let the actors improv so
in addition to deleted scenes there's
just a lot of scenes that went on and on
and on because they just kept going
and the directors would just have to
yell cut for time like okay you know we
don't need to keep talking we just need
to move on to the next scene
so for instance you have to imagine a
version of the scene where they're
talking about the plan
and iron man gets really fed up with
star-lord imagine that scene just goes
on for a couple more minutes
what exactly is it that they do kick
names take
ass yeah that's right we gotta call us
because if all we come at them with us a
plucky attitude dude
don't call us plucky we don't know what
it means
all right we're optimistic yes i like
your plan except
it sucks so let me do the plan and that
way it might be really good
tell them about the dance off to save
the universe what dance off
it's not it's not a it's not i can flush
the move exactly like footloose
is it still the greatest movie in
history it never was when they get into
the edit bay they just cut that way down
because a lot of it's them just having
fun on set
marvel's usually pretty good about the
stuff they put on their blu-rays they
don't skimp too much and infinity war is
the biggest movie they've ever done so
there are more bonus features than we've
seen on previous releases
the only thing that doesn't appear on
this list is a director's commentary and
it would be weird of the russos not to
do a director's commentary when they've
done one for
every marvel movie that they've done so
far so don't be surprised if there are a
couple extra things on the blu-ray when
they officially announce it like this
list might not be totally complete
so what will happen is there's a whole
bunch more marvel stuff that happened
this week i'll try to get through those
videos as fast as possible
leave your requests in the comments
below congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner
felix please private message me so i can
get your contact details
everybody click here for brand new
spider-man and click here for my video
about the avengers 4 title
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight